some nasty cross between the hollywood
squares and the brady bunch here we are
welcome to football week in america mike
taurico tony dungy is it this way no no
tony's this way there you go florio's
looking down the right way rodney's down
here i got that
it's good to be with you all uh you know
guys we're gonna have this i think
after uh three weeks of the nfl season
we thought okay things are cool
uh this covet 19 thing is figured out
but maybe we got lulled by the bubbles
in the nba and the nhl to think once you
got in it was all going to be smooth and
we have this week in floria i'll start
with you the news as we're taping this
just a short time ago that the
titans game against the steelers will be
postponed till monday or tuesday what
have you been hearing in the
conversations last day or so mike
well i mean and the good news is a
short-term postponement because it seems
to be engineered to give the titans a
chance to go back to their facility on
saturday get a couple of practices in
and have a fair chance to have a fair
game against a steelers team that has
every opportunity to get ready to face
the tennessee titans so
now that the testing has come back with
only one additional positive titans
player as of today and they'll surely
keep testing every day given the
incubation period there is encouragement
that they've gotten this contained that
it's not going to be a massive outbreak
that none of the vikings players caught
it during the game on sunday which
confirms the league's belief that in an
open-air setting or in a dome with great
ventilation you're not going to have
transmission from one team to the next
the greater risk is transmission among
the players and coaches on a given team
so
it's good news
it's not perfect news but it should
serve as a wake-up call to the league
because i think we'd start to get a
little complacent after three weeks
they're like yeah this is going to work
out this is going to be fine we got a
reminder this week it may not be fun
everybody needs to be careful all year
long
i'm going to let tony rodney go and ask
you questions and get their thoughts on
what this deal is i just got one more
for you mike
this was saturday night sunday it's now
wednesday as we're talking here the
incubation period is a week or so the
question even though guys are testing
negative we still don't know yet how
limited the outbreak is we hope this is
a good sign that everyday testing has
been going on
is there conversation around the people
you've talked to that we don't know yet
this is really i hate to say trial and
error but it's a little bit of that at
this point trying to figure out what the
parameters are going to be to know a
team is relatively clean going into
competition
there's definitely an element of
everyone holding their breath and
waiting for the daily results to come in
and hoping that the numbers don't
continue
to grow one at a time two at a time etc
and the question becomes will they feel
comfortable come saturday that they can
allow the titans players back into the
facility because even with all of the
measures in place to limit the spread
you don't want anyone in there who still
hasn't gotten to the point where they've
tested positive yet or that the test
they they give a sample for on saturday
when they're admitted to the building
comes back a day later that they were
positive that the incubation period
finally hit so there is some concern
there but they're handling this the way
that they expected to this isn't a
surprise as the commissioner said
yesterday and they're just trying to
make good decisions while
there is a certain amount of hold your
breath and wait to see how it all plays
out
tony what do you think about all this
you know when i worked for denny green
back in the late 90s he used to practice
these type of things uh and they would
never ever come up but i think
this is what uh coaches have talked
about all year hey we're going to have
to be flexible things are going to
happen that we couldn't expect how are
we going to react to it the teams that
are in the in the running in the hunt at
the end of the year are going to be
teams that deal with uncertainty and
deal with change the best so this is
going to be a test i think everybody was
kind of waiting for something like this
and now we have to see how people
respond but it's going to be a challenge
all year no question
and i think just after talking to a
couple players and i asked them would
you be comfortable going out there
playing they said you know yeah every
week is a challenge because you just
don't know who's infected or what what's
going on behind the scenes
but i think the message in the locker
room mike needs to be you need to
continue to be careful diligent do all
this you know follow all the safety
protocols and don't get relaxed i live
out here in atlanta and you can go out
in the streets and you see people going
to clubs going to gym and everybody's
kind of put their guard down with this
whole covet thing
so i think the message has to be from
player to player hey we have to continue
to do what we have to do throughout the
entire nfl
right so let me just ask you one more
thing about tennessee then we'll move on
to other stuff so you're uh you're a
player for the titans
and your facilities shut down until
saturday you're doing all this stuff
virtually
if you can't get back in the facility
until then can you be ready to play a
game on a monday or tuesday
i think they're definitely at a
competitive disadvantage mike because
you want to be in the facility you want
to have access to all the tape and film
and you want to be able to communicate
with your coaches that's a big part of
preparation because when you're there
and you're practicing you get a chance
to see mistakes make mistakes and talk
and confer with your your coaches right
there and it's nothing like being there
at the facility on the practice field
being around your teammates so i i
definitely believe if if they're not
able to do that it's definitely a
competitive disadvantage for them
and tony did all the stuff in the off
season help these guys
yeah they can and we face that all the
time one team has a buy the other team's
coming off a monday night game or you
you have to play a thursday game and you
only have three days so i think as a
coach you have to really stress that hey
no excuses no explanations we can't let
this impact us this is just like a bad
call on the
field we've got to overcome it and i
don't think you're going to hear coaches
talk about that you're not going to hear
them make excuses i agree with rodney
there is a competitive disadvantage but
you can't let your team feel
that all right i'm gonna let the
defensive minds take over here guys uh
through three weeks of the nfl season
51 points per game is the average
last year
the record was set excuse me 2012 the
record was set
47.7 points per game so points per game
keep going up up up axios visuals did
this chart this jumped out to me a
little bit
tony why why why are we seeing this
well when i came in the league you would
open up the season the defenses would
always be ahead of the offenses and the
offenses would get their timing down
they would catch up then the great
offenses were playing great around the
playoffs but ever since we went to this
off-season program and changed training
camp and everything it's always been
tough on the defense the offense can
work out peyton manning can take his
guys to duke and and throw for two
months and donovan mcnabb can take his
guys to phoenix arizona and they can all
throw and work out defenses don't have
that luxury well i think you've seen
that accentuated times 10 with this
tom brady is down here i live in tampa
he's at berkeley high school every day
with his receivers throwing they're
getting groove defenses as you say
watching on a zoom meeting so they had
the advantage and uh it's i don't know
when the defenses are going to catch up
but for this first month or two
definitely i thought baltimore you know
being a good defense would have a chance
to slow kansas city down they had no
shot it wasn't even close so i think
that's what we're going to be dealing
with for the next
five or six weeks anyway
coach the defense will never catch up
you know why because the rule changes
when you sit back and watch film think
about it patrick mcholmes and lamar
jackson they're throwing you know slants
across the middle deep posts
deep digs inside no one's afraid of
getting hit no one's afraid of the
safety coming down and smacking a wide
receiver because these safeties and
these defensive backs and linebackers
they're afraid once they hit first thing
they're look doing is looking around
seeing if a ref is going to throw a
penalty or something like that so i
think the rules changes have real
changes have really affected what the
defense can do and the confidence in
which they can play mike florio
well and there's another element too
here as well it was a great item from
kevin c for vspn.com today looking at
the dramatic reduction
in holding penalties remember it was a
couple of weeks ago second sunday of the
season walt anderson now a supervisor of
officials said in an item posted at
nfl.com the officials have been told
this year to only call clear and obvious
fouls it would have been nice for the
teams to know that before week one so
they could have coached it but that's
what's happening now the coaches are
coaching it the holding penalties are
happening but they're not being called
that's boosting the offense and the way
that the story was written and i can't
say i disagree with it it creates the
idea that this is what the nfl wanted
that the nfl wanted to goose scoring
they fell the nfl wanted to not have the
game bogged down by a bunch of penalties
people were complaining about that for
years so now the penalties are down the
scoring is up and everyone's happy
i'll tell you one more factor in that
and one reason why the
holding penalties are down they may be
getting instructed not to call it
no crowd noise if you have great pass
rushers and i was with derek thomas and
chris doleman john randall warren sapp
those guys get 70 percent of their
sacks at home
and now all of a sudden we're watching
on monday night or yes monday night and
patrick mahomes is saying no no no let's
turn it to 15. block it here hey we're
good over there everybody can hear
they're going on two and on three in the
visiting stadium or when they're
visiting and
in the past it was silent snap count
tackles can't hear i get beat a little
bit i have to reach out and grab none of
that is happening these veteran
quarterbacks on the road are carving up
good defenses
hey mike tony rodney i was just going to
say that because
aaron rodgers told us that on saturday
before our sunday night game and that's
exactly what happened and matt lafleur
rodney said i think we're going to look
at that here for a while until there are
fans back in the stands because not only
are you drawing guys off and aaron did
it a couple of times and made it pay
you're also slowing down the defense too
they can't time it up it's not off the
silent count and it's just an advantage
and look at the packers i think they've
allowed two sacks one in the first two
games and demario davis was a free
rusher outnumbered off the left side and
nobody touched him and he got rogers on
the first drive of the game other than
that i think that's been about it for
green bay so rodney the defenses are
playing at really a double disadvantage
if you're not getting those flags you
can't hit across the middle and you're
playing at home with guys going with a
hard count against you well what
organization really changed the rules
after um losing in a particular game
they come back and completely change the
rules where you can't jam a receiver
past five yards and i think that's a big
part of it because you look at all i'm
saying is mike you look at kansas city
chiefs and they're up and down the field
and no one absolutely no one and you
talk about the patriots and the key to
the game is being physical with these
guys these guys run 4-2 run 4-3
and no one's jamming them at the line of
scrimmage no one wants to touch them
because they're afraid of a legal
contact or a holding penalty and i don't
know which organization did it but i
know some a certain organization changed
everything coach well
let me go back with all due respect to
chris wallace with all due respect to
chris wallace i'm going to give coach
dungey a chance to reply
let me say this
i was around when the rules got changed
in 1976
okay and the rules have been there for
35 40 years that you can jam at the line
of scrimmage you can be physical you
just can't jam eight and ten yards down
the field so in this particular game
that mr harrison is referencing
that's what was talked about not
changing the rule but enforcing the rule
so that those patriots had to jam within
five yards
so
i understand what you're saying it's a
valid point but the rules didn't change
in 2004 they changed in 1976.
just so we're close unfortunately let me
add something good mike
the extent that they only are going to
throw a flag when it's clear and obvious
i'm reminded of the legion of boom 2013
time frame where they just decided you
know what we're going to grab them on
every play they're not going to throw a
flag on every place so rodney that may
be what the patriots need to do on
sunday just grab them on every play and
force the officials to throw the flag
i have no comment mike tarico
wow do you see i spoke my piece did have
an
people are ready to just let their words
stand and not continue debating mike
it's a really good point i will tell you
that i spoke to a coach in the last week
or so who talked about just that team x
i'll leave them unnamed for the purposes
of our view of our conversation team x
holds on every play they can't call
defensive holding downfield on every
play so they've got to call the
egregious ones that doesn't mean that we
can get free because they are holding on
every play but that's been an age-old
debate you brought it up so rodney i
want to start with you how is the new
england defense that secondary that
you've talked about is the key to that
unit how will they do in your mind how
can they approach patrick mahomes after
what belichick and those guys watched on
monday night as they went against a good
defense in baltimore and walked it up
and down the field the first half well
you see a lot of times mike i think
defenses give them too much respect you
got to get in their face man the one
thing that you have to do that stands
out to me every time i watch kansas city
play is you got to try to take away the
big play to tyre kill when he makes the
big plays it just fuels their offense it
gets their offense so pumped up but it
opens up so many things in the middle
with travis kelsey the screen game out
of the backfield with the running backs
it's so many different things that you
have to deal with it puts so much
pressure on the defense but the number
one thing you have to do is you have to
take away the big play and and i see the
patriots getting up there being physical
you maybe put jonathan jones on tyreek
hill with a safety double teaming him
and forcing kelsey and some of these
other guys to make plays and you're
gonna you're gonna force them to go 10
12 play drives you can't allow them just
two or three plays and it's a 60 yard
touchdown coach i see you shaking your
head yeah no you you're so right and i
think that's uh chiefs are going to
struggle a little bit with the changes
that new england is going to make and
they will do some things to take away
that big play to tyreek hill the two
things i would be worried about if i
were new england is they'll have some
great coverages and and things that will
confuse my homes a little bit
the back out of the backfield clyde
edwards a lair on those linebackers and
then patrick mahomes running when you
double cover a bunch of people and you
have these different coverages he hurt
baltimore several times in key
situations running
i think you can look for that on sunday
as well
and i think the last point too is from
from an offensive standpoint the offense
needs to help the defense if the
patriots have success running the ball
controlling the clock keeping patrick my
homes on the sideline they're going to
have a really good shot of winning the
game because a lot of times those
offenses they're so used to being on the
field they get anxious and when they get
on the field and they're not making
those big plays they get frustrated but
kansas city i tell you kansas city is a
very patient offense you can't take away
everything that they do but some of the
most important things like you talked
about coach defending the back out of
the backfield the screen game to the
wide receiver some of those intricacies
you have to you have to definitely try
to slow down mike hey
before you hop in mike what's up what's
that i just wanna ask tony
just on rodney's point there tony does
it help
kansas city at all that you've just
played baltimore
unique little bit different offense do
so much out of the run game and then to
follow that up playing new england which
is in more of a similar vein than let's
say rogers and the packers or the
passing happy outfits
no i think what is going to help kansas
city is the fact that eric b enemy andy
reed and patrick mahomes have been
together now for these three years
they're going to see something totally
unique from from the patriots something
they didn't expect and how quick they
have to adjust to it but these guys do i
mean they're very good patrick mahomes
has a million plays he can go to andy
reid and the enemy dial them up they're
going to have a tough time figuring it
out early but i think they'll adjust and
adapt
see i i disagree with you coach because
i don't think the patriots are going to
try to throw something super exotic on
them because they have so many things
and they've seen everything everybody's
tried to blitz some drop
you know blitz cornerbacks dropped
defensive linemans they've seen
everything but i think the most
important thing is knowing your
assignment don't give up any blown
coverages any you know mistakes in the
secondary and putting pressure i mean
the los angeles chargers did a great job
two weeks ago when they played them
because they hit patrick mahomes and
they slowed him down it wasn't like you
know they sacked him a bunch of times
but just constantly hitting him putting
pressure on him every time he dropped
back he had to pay attention to their
pass rushers
i don't know that blitzing makes a
difference that's what the titans
decided last year because you're not
going to get him and he torched the
ravens defense the other night but
rodney on your point regarding the new
england offense
i think that
when you play the chiefs your offense
has to score points when it can you
can't kick a field goal when you're
inside the 10 on the first drive of the
game you got to go for seven you got to
score your points you have to accept
that at some point the chiefs are going
to be like that basketball team that
goes on an 18-2 run that's just what
they are so you need to prepare yourself
for you need to score your points and
the other thing you can't do and we saw
this from lamar jackson when the ravens
were down 34-20 he had that demeanor of
a guy who was frustrated and defeated
you can't have that and that's a lesson
to cam newton because we've seen that at
at times from him in the past they need
to focus on scoring points whenever they
can and not worry about what the chiefs
are doing otherwise they're not going to
have a chance to end up with at least
one more point on the scoreboard than
the chiefs have
all right we have to wrap up guys but i
want to get a brief word here on the
sunday night game the 49ers with
everybody out right missing 11 starters
go to
back to new jersey and beat the giants
after they beat the jet so they leave
two and oh but even more beat up but now
they'll come back and take on the eagles
who tied yet gain game game day game or
gain ground i should say on everyone in
their division because everybody else
lost the cowboys and the washington
football team and the giants uh tony let
me start with you on the philadelphia
situation uh what is your largest area
of concern with that eagles offense
after watching them here for three weeks
now
well to me they've got to generate some
running game and be balanced not expect
uh carson wentz to have to do everything
and then he's got to
understand that he doesn't have to be
superman either he's got to make the
plays that are available but not put
himself in harm's way holding the ball
trying to make too much happen and
certainly not turn it over
coach i agree with you and i put the
pressure on doug peterson because he's
the head coach he's responsible for
making sure that his team is prepared
and you look at carson wentz he's just
overthinking everything and that's doug
peterson's job to kind of simplify
things bring him back and he's holding
the ball you know he's got a guy wide
open he doesn't want that then he looks
downfield and before you know it the
offensive line caves in i just think
they have to get back to doing simple
things and run the offense through miles
sanders it can't be carson wentz
dropping back trying to save the day
he's just not that talented
of a of a player but he's also he's not
playing with that level of confidence
either
and i just need to say this to all
eagles fans out there
you won a super bowl within the last
three years
it's way too premature to start calling
for everyone to be fired and that's what
they're doing get rid of howie roseman
get rid of doug peterson get rid of
carson wentz make jeff flurry sell the
team folks sometimes it takes time and i
think there's so much pressure on carson
wentz because of that because he wasn't
the quarterback for the super bowl win
because they picked him over nick foles
they paid him the contract they need to
find ways to let him build his
confidence during games because it does
feel like he's trying to do too much to
justify the faith that the team has in
him and to to quiet all the folks in
philly who don't appreciate the fact
that there's a fairly new lombardi
trophy in the lobby to the facility
mike mike i just want to make one last
year i just want to make one last more
point about doug peterson the thing that
i'm really kind of just
like stunned about doug peterson has
changed his complete mindset before it
was a i'm going forward on fourth down
he had an arrogance and a confidence in
his team now all of a sudden he's
playing for ties he's conservative and
it's like come on doug like what court
what kind of coach are you going to be
you're totally different than what you
were before and coach you talked about
it when they had success they were
running the football they got to get
back to running the football controlling
the line of scrimmage and you look at a
guy like jason peters who moved from
guard to to left tackle he looks
terrible why would you put a guy that's
so old he can't move he can't handle
those young pass rushes and you wonder
why they're struggling offensively
and they've run out of options with all
the injuries tony i'm just curious
as a coach are there times that you know
that your team you just can't get them
there you know whether it's offensive
line injuries or what's going on that
you can't be as aggressive as you'd like
to be because
the guys you have right now aren't in a
place to execute at that level at this
moment
you definitely have more confidence when
you have your veteran players and things
are rolling but
you guys hit on one great point and i
think rodney said it running the
football when
nick foles played that was a big part of
it and then you didn't get that
tremendous pass rush because so many of
the passes were off the rpo and the
defensive linemen were reading run they
weren't teeing off and rushing the
passer so i think they've got to get
back to that
and help that offensive line a little
bit
256 and 256 i think that's going to be
my website because every fan base does
not believe that
every team does lose a game
you can't win every game your team can
there are an even number of wins and
losses in the league every year and you
go city to city i was just in new
orleans was listening to the folks in
green bay back home in michigan everyone
wants to know what's wrong with their
team somebody does have to lose every
game it's sometimes
mike what's up 56
what is the number of games in the six
games oh okay yeah
every everybody wins one everybody loses
at the end of the day rodney and you
know what actually it's not the case
because we already had a tie so
[Laughter]
i'm gonna say this that tie may help
philadelphia win at the end of the year
that may not have been the worst thing
in the world if you try that 58-yard
field goal and you miss and you turn the
ball over the bengals get one play
they're in field goal range that's a
loss for you that might in a division
where you know eight and eight nine and
seven already is looking good at the
start of october that might be uh might
be helping philadelphia down the line
all right guys we'll talk about the
49ers where we're all together for uh
football night and chris sims joins us
have a safe travels great rest of your
week we look forward to everybody sunday
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports